like and subscribe
hey guys welcome back to the anime
culture corner even though fall 2020
seriously has some amazing anime for us
what's lingering on most of our minds is
surely winter 2021 the season of
sexy ass sequels promise neverland
re-zero
dr stone and last but certainly not
least attack on titan season
4 aka the last season i read the manga
and i can tell you
it's going to be an insane season to say
the least and the manga isn't even done
yet
but i'm not here to talk about the manga
at all actually and this is an anime
only video
about everything you need to know for
the anime before the fourth and final
season comes around
spoiler warning only to people who
haven't watched seasons one through
three
let's get it we ended last season
learning about the truth about what's
outside the walls
the secret of the basement that we've
been longing to learn about since attack
on titan anime first aired in 2013
yes seven whole years ago let that sink
in
grisha aaron's father fought for the
freedom of the eldians
the eldians are a race descended from
yamir the original progenitor of all
nine titan shifters
and was the original founding titan who
we know is now inside of aaron
he has both the attack titan and the
founding titan and if you forgot the
name of the show
shingeki no kyojin is named after the
attack titan within aaron we're all
credits
but back to the aldians they essentially
shaped the history of the main continent
breeding and expanding the aldean race
until the marlins froze up and
successfully defeated them
taking seven of the nine titan shifters
for their own there's an interesting
contradiction between how the marlians
and how the aliens view history
grisha describes amir's actions as
beneficial for the advancement of the
life on the main continent
while the marlins essentially frame it
as mass genocide both of which are
probably true and for future reference
there's the main continent where
marlians live
and paradise which is the island that
all of our favorite characters live on
and we know that the two other titans
who weren't taken by marley were the
attack titan
passed down from aaron krueger to grisha
to aaron jaeger
and the founding titan which went from
the original king of the walls down to
the royal bloodline
and is now also in aaron and so we've
seen eight of nine titans the beast and
zeke
the cart the jaw which was in the mirror
not the progenitor ymir but historia's
friend yumir
the colossal now held by armin the
female an annie who's being held
somewhere within the walls
the armored and of course the attack
titan and founding within aaron this
leaves one unaccounted for within marley
remember that there's also something
incredibly interesting that happened in
aaron kruger's last moments with grisha
on the wall
telling him to save armin and mikasa and
the others
how the does he know about them decades
before they're even born
since this is of course the last season
it's no spoiler to say that we will
figure this out
and it might blow your mind there was
also an unexplained moment when aaron
kissed to story his hand after receiving
his medal of honor after the battle at
walmaria
where he looks extremely unsettled after
seeing memories of his fathers the night
he ate the founding titan
which is strange because he's clearly
been witnessing his father's memories
for days leading up to this point
so what made this one stand out aaron
also realized that when he used the
power of the founding titan in season 2
it was because the titan who he punched
was in fact dina fritz the former wife
of his father grisha mother of zeke
and descendant of the royal family who
are the only people who can wield the
founding titan's powers
this implies that contact with a royal
family member allows aaron access to his
true powers
i'm sure this is the reason behind his
shock and seeing whatever happened when
historia let him kiss her hand
as she is royal blood it's fair to say
that we still have a lot to learn about
aaron's powers in both the attack titan
and the founding
so what's happening with everyone else
armin feels guilty about being given
life over irwin
and certainly levi feels some of this
burden as well my theory on why he gave
it to armin
well i think it's because armin has more
potential erwin has believed for a long
time that history was faked
which it was but never really acted on
it i think that the change levi sees
armand making
and potential in this new generation of
scouts is the reason he let armin live
knowing that he could bring forward the
shift in history that irwin was unable
to do
mikasa is skinnier and aaron is
wondering whether eliminating everyone
on the mainland will save the eldings
within the walls
a dangerous idea but one that we saw in
grisha his father as well
the question of who deserves to live the
aldeans within the wall who have never
done anything to harm marlians but carry
the blood of devils
or the marlins who have suppressed and
tortured aliens for decades now in
repentance of the likely equally bad
if not worse crimes their ancestors
committed
i mean i'm taking air inside here but
the line's pretty blurry
and so here we are on the forefront of a
new continent and the complete shift in
the plot of attack on titan
creating a world bigger than what i'm
sure any of us initially expected from
the show
from revealing the last titans to what
aaron saw when he touched astoria to
what his plan even is moving forward
we've essentially begun an entirely new
show as we begin season 4 with so many
more questions than answers
and i know for a fact that this season
will go down in history so get hype
as always this has been the anime
culture corner don't forget to like and
subscribe for future in-depth show manga
and character analyses